ja unendlich erklärt sich der kanzler
warum hat er geschwiegen als der
palästinenserpräsident abbas direkt
neben ihm im kanzleramt den holocaust
relativiert hat warum hat er nichts
gesagt
jetzt schreibt scholz bei twitter jetzt
nach zwölf stunden empörter sich der
kanzler schreib ich bin zutiefst empört
über die unsäglichen aussagen von mahmud
abbas gerade für uns deutsche ist
jegliche relativierung des holocaust
unerträglich inakzeptabel ich verurteile
jeden versuch die verbrechen des
holocaust zu leugnen dass schreibt olaf
scholz also heute ja mehr als zwölf
stunden nach dem genau das im kanzleramt
passiert war
mahmud abbas zu besuch beim kanzler
der chef der palästinensischen
autonomiebehörde
er wird empfangen nur wenige tage
nachdem tausende raketen aus den
palästinensergebieten auf israel
abgefeuert wurden umso beziehungen sind
eng und vielfältig gemeinsame auftritt
vor der presse scholz und abbas und
dabei kommt es zum skandal
der palästinenserpräsident er offen den
holocaust relativiert und
der kanzler der dazu schweigt ein
journalist fragt bei abbas nach einer
entschuldigung 50 jahre nach dem terror
bei den olympischen spielen von münchen
gibt es dafür eine offizielle
entschuldigung herr
palästinenserpräsident und er antwortet
so
seit 1947 bis zum heutigen tag hat
israel 50 massaker in 50
palästinensischen dörfern und städten
begangen
tante war afrikas ihm und viele weitere
50 massaker 50 holocaust und das bis zum
heutigen tag 50 holocaust dann durch
israel einen skandal aussage im
kanzleramt
unter den augen des kanzlers wie
reagiert er nun
gar nicht der kanzler schweigt mehr noch
er gibt abbas die hand wenige sekunden
nachdem er den holocaust relativiert hat
so etwas hat es im kanzleramt noch nie
gegeben
eine regierungssprecherin erklärt am
abend zu bild bevor der kanzler diesem
ungeheuerlichen satz wieder sprechen
konnte hatte der regierungssprecher die
pressekonferenz schon wie üblich nach
dem letzten frage antwort block ab
moderiert was scholz sichtlich
verärgerter daraufhin teilte der
regierungssprecher die noch anwesenden
journalisten denen die verärgerung des
kanzlers nicht entgangen war mit wie
empörter kanzler über die aussage war
und auch darüber dass er keine
gelegenheit hatte ein weiteres mal offen
zu widersprechen doch längst hat die
welt gesehen wie scholz geschwiegen hat
die opposition entsetzt friedrich merz
twittert ein unfassbarer vorgang im
kanzleramt der bundeskanzler hätte die
palästinenser präsident klar und
deutlich wieder sprechen und ihn bitten
müssen das haus zu verlassen
und auch israels ministerpräsident zeigt
sich enttäuscht und entsetzt
rapid schreibt dass mahmud abbas israel
beschuldigt 50 holocaust begangen zu
haben während er auf deutschem boden
steht ist nicht nur eine moralische
schande sondern eine ungeheuerliche lüge
so israels ministerpräsident er ist
selbst sohn eines holocaust-überlebenden
der palästinenserpräsident
relativiert den holocaust
und der kanzler er schweigt
ein absoluter tiefpunkt im kanzleramt
darüber wollen wir sprechen mit bild lei
chef claus strunz hallo klaus der
kanzler olaf scholz schweigt
entscheidenden moment was sagt uns das
über seinen charakter naja es gibt ja
schon momente in denen sich entscheidet
ob ein großer ist oder eben kein großer
und dieser moment hat klar gestellt dass
olaf scholz kein großer bundeskanzler
ist und das womöglich auch nicht werden
kann weil ihm das format für solche
momente fehlt es fehlt die mir nicht das
wissen es fehlen die mir auch nicht die
haltung ist die überzeugung aber ist für
sie team ganz offensichtlich in einer
solchen situation ein zeichen zu setzen
außerhalb des protokolls olaf scholz ist
ein protokoll ab arbeiter aber kein
großer bundeskanzler das ist deutlich
geworden in der ein oder andere das
vorher schon geahnt gab ja auch schon
die unsägliche situation mit zielinski
als zielinski bundestag geredet hat eine
große rede gehalten hat eine emotionale
rede gehalten hat und olaf scholz
sitzengeblieben ist auf seinem kanzler
stuhl ohne darauf einzugehen spontan
sich zum zu bedanken die unterstützung
persönlich zu zu überliefern hat er
einfach das protokoll weiter gemacht und
wir erinnern uns olaf scholz ist ja auch
als erster bürgermeister von hamburg
schon mal sehr unangenehm aufgefallen
als 2017 beim g20-gipfel die ganze stadt
abgebrannt ist nach dem
linksradikale idioten feuer gelegt haben
und bomben und und linkskurven das saß
er in der elbphilharmonie und hat sich
gemütlich mit den anderen staatschefs
und musik angehört dh ihm fehlt ganz
offensichtlich der kompass für den
entscheidenden moment und das gibt einem
natürlich das ungute gefühl ob ihn in
wichtigen situationen während eines
krieges beispielsweise an dem wir nicht
beteiligt sind da aber ja stattfindet
vor unserer haustür oder in großen
zukunftsfragen in dem moment wo es nur
auf ihn ankommt nicht auf die leute die
etwas aufgeschrieben haben nicht auf die
leute die das protokoll gemacht haben
nicht auf den regierungssprecher auf den
jetzt alles geschoben wird der als
offenbar die macht hat dem kanzler das
wort zu verbieten und abzuschneiden wenn
es nur auf ihnen an kommt dann hat er
bisher nicht gezeigt dass er das format
für dieses amt hat fehlt es an
menschlichkeit einem menschlichen
fingerspitzengefühl und geht das auch so
einer langen politischen biografie
langen politischen reise möglicherweise
verloren weil man trainiert wird darauf
aus protokoll also ich glaube ja dass
jetzt genau in diese stunden des olaf
scholz umtreibt dass er diesen fehler
diesen fatalen fehler begangen hat er
hat damit im prinzip einen skandal
produziert der deutschland auch ganz
schlecht dastehen lässt ende soll man
denn von dem land halten das sich
ständig selbst vergewissert nie wieder
die holocaust leugner und relativiere
unter strafe stellt und dann kommt der
palästinenserpräsident und leugnet
beziehungsweise relativiert den
holocaust im kanzleramt im beisein des
deutschen bundeskanzlers und es passiert
nichts
ich glaube nicht dass es
fingerspitzengefühl oder so ist ich
stelle jetzt aber die frage nach vorn
was folgt jetzt eigentlich daraus also
zwingend ist eine entschuldigung von
olaf scholz denn in kürze kommt ja der
israelische staatspräsident nach
deutschland der im bundestag reden will
da sitzen die dann in einem raum wie
sollte es denn nach diesem vorfall
eigentlich noch gehen da muss eine
entschuldigung her und eigentlich
bevor man immer in die situation kommt
alles besser zu wissen was hätte denn
was etwas hätte eigentlich geschehen
müssen aus meiner sicht hätte geschehen
müssen dass olaf scholz ganz klar den
handschlag verweigert erstens zweitens
mit deutlichen worten die relativierung
des holocaust zurückweist und drittens
abbas des hauses verweist er den roche
meist müssen um es kurz zu machen und
jetzt müsste er da sitzen und müsse sich
überlegen was kann man eigentlich an den
vielen millionen zuwendungen
subventionen hilfspaketen die von
unserem steuergeld an palästinenser
ausbezahlt wird an menschen die diesen
mann verehren was kann da eigentlich in
zukunft noch ausgezahlt werden aus
meiner sicht müssen da einschnitte
folgen und dann könnten palästinenser
sagen das haben wir diesen mann zu
verdanken der in deutschland diese
ungeheuerlichkeit begangen hat die man
niemanden anderen durchgehen lassen
würde also zusammengefasst lag es daran
dass olaf scholz sich nur nach dem
protokoll gerichtet hat und nicht
entsprechend reagiert hat oder es ist
tatsächlich eine charakterschwäche nein
ich glaube also ich würde nicht so weit
den urlaub scholz zu unterstellen dass
er irgendwie diesem gedankengang geistig
nahe ist oder so das ist ich glaube es
ein gefangener von protokoll er möchte
alles richtig abarbeiten also wieso uns
super beamter oder wer der beste der
wird wahrscheinlich der beste
beamte im passamt neukölln da wird alles
genau dass wir alles genau in ordnung er
wäre wahrscheinlich ein herausragender
sparkassendirektor in lüdenscheid das
ist alles perfekt und er hat politische
ämter gehabt in denen er auch gut war
aber es waren eben ämter wo er immer
noch vorgesetzte hatte die absolute
nummer eins zu sein hat er jetzt zweimal
in entscheidenden momenten nicht auf die
reihe gekriegt den hamburger als
bürgermeister nicht und jetzt auch als
bundeskanzler
[Musik]